pop
[Applaudissements]
il revient dans ma mémoire des souvenirs
familier
je reçois ma blouse noire lorsque
j'étais écolier sur le chemin de l'école
je chantais à pleine voix des romances
sans paroles vieilles chansons d'autres
foires
tous ces français
cher pays de mon enfance
[Musique]
bercée de tendre insouciance
j'étais garder dans mon coeur
mon village
je recherchais aux maisons aux sages
où les enfants de mon âge je partager
mon bonheur
[Musique]
oui je t'ai
je te donne ce prêt
oui je t'aime
dans la chambre noire ou la douleur
nous ferons faire pays de mon enfance
bercée de prendre insouciance
je n'ai gardé dans mon coeur
j'ai connu des paysages des soleils
merveilleux au cours de lointains
voyages tout là-bas tout d'autres cieux
mes bouquins je leur préfère mon ciel
bleu
mon horizon magon route ma rivière des
prairies et ma maison
ce moment
ce
cher pays de mon enfance
percée de tendre insouciant
je sais garder dans mon coeur
mon village au clocher ou maison sage
où les enfants de mona
[Musique]
repartager mon bonheur
oh
oui je t'ai
et je te donne ce prêt
oui je t'aime
dans la joie ou la douleur
de douce france cher pays de mon enfant
rcd badr insouciance j'ai des gars est
dans mon coeur
goethe également dans mon coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]